charlie munger and warren buffett like
those guys are my absolute
heroes in terms of how they live their
lives and how they make decisions and
how they think through things if you
look at the people who are billionaires
right
many of them create it through software
now what i feel like is not represented
is the many people who tried to create
it with software and failed once you
become billionaires
it's like vc if i bet on 50
one of them or two of them are gonna hit
it right but if you're the entrepreneur
in the one your success likelihood is
far lower whereas i feel like if i
invest the way that i plan on investing
i will have a vehicle that compounds
capital at a very high rate of return
and i can diversify my risk and
virtually guarantee that i get there
it's a risk analysis that's the
overarching reasoning behind it now that
being said maybe in three years we'll
get on here and i'll be like you know
what man i was full of [ __ ] i saw the
software opportunity and i crushed it